[Music]
um
[Music]
in ghana coffins can look like this
they're carved into whimsical shapes and
painted bright colors meant to represent
a person's life or occupation
[Music]
okay but driving okay
anon and his family are at the center of
these extravagantly designed
larger-than-life coffins made in the
shape of whatever one desires
yeah
it started about 65 years ago with an
odd request from a chief to be buried in
a coffin shaped like a cocoa pod
from there the requests kept coming in
and anan's father realized he had a
serious business on his hands
while funerals are a sad occasion in
ghana many also see them as an
opportunity to celebrate the deceased
celebrity
when an order comes in for one of their
coffins they first get the measurements
of the deceased
carve the wood into the shape of the
family's choosing
create an opening and stand it for
smoothness
it then goes to an artist for painting
once the interior's stuffed it's ready
to be delivered to the family and these
coffins are not only delivered locally
in los angeles and i can work a
decapitated german
denmark russia
as fernan he already has his picked out
once morning
afternoon
he was too snoozy
[Music]
you